Friend of mine she is asking me like within
you Muslims it is yourself you have
confusion like one you meet you ask first the question is whether
you are a Wahhabi and a
Sunni what ever this kind of question there is
confusion between you it is yourself what do you want us to
follow what is that we can at least come
follow and the sister is the question
the non muslim sister ask
the confusion among the muslim when you meet you
ask you are a Wahhabi a
Muslim r a r w a n Muslim sister
anally many muslim k name but l Hindu u
go b ku Veda mum o b q raan
Allah Quran
[Music] Do
not hold to the rope of Allah strung and be
not divided we have to hold to the rope of
Allah The rope of Allah is the Glorious
Quran and the authentic hadi Allah says in the
Quran in sra anonymous chapter number verse
number  159 That any one who makes division in the
region of Islam O Prophet you have nothing to do with him
making sex making division in
Islam is prohibited it is haram but when we
ask the Muslim what are you some say I am a Hanafi some say Amam
Shafii some say Hamali some say
Salafi what wa the Prophet wa the Prophet Hanafi wa
Shafi wa Hamli wa Maliki
wa hi wa Muslim ala
Iran n 52 I Salam Jesus p Muslim ala
Iran 67 Ibram p Apna Muslim ala
inra 4
33 But speak one of all righteousness and say that
I am a Muslim a big Prophet Muhammad s
wa Muslim Allah told us to call us
Muslim they can not be a better label than
Muslim see all these four great Amaz Imams Imam
Abu Hanifa Imam Shafi Imam Ahmad in habl
Imam Malik may Allah be pleased with them all these
great Scholars I love them I
respect  All of them were great scholars but all these
great scholars said all this Fama said that if you find any of
my fatwa which goes
against Allah and His Rasool then you
throw my fatwa on the
wall
so if you analyze that this Imam that came they came
not to make a new sex they came
for the people to go back to the original
scripture the Quran hadi so what we have to
believe is that I know there are people set in hadi
in the prophet said they will be 73 sec it hadi
of r hadi number 171 the prophet said they will be
7 sec prophet you should
make prophet even Allah says don't make bound
to make so the best is to go back to Allah
and His Rasool and the best label you can have is
call yourself a Muslim any scholar let it be any one
in the world let him be the
biggest caller of the world you ask him for
Proof Nanak Praise your proof if you are truth
full if you must produce your proof so
any scholar if there is difference of opinion you
ask him for proof get the proof check it up there
for in my talk aa always give
references what I say what Zakir says rubbish
in Islam it is zero null there for I say
Zakir Allah
Ali zero Ilam
Allah is
prophet so sister Muslim should not be
divided wa should kal Muslim and follow the Quran
andwa
[praise]
no yes
brother Dr Mahadev practicing medical
practitioner day before yesterday I attended
Mr Abdul Rahim Green
lecture we po ba
medical
student aa
about para
prax ilam parada a rest people go he
aran ba mist now no can you please
explain thank
you brother the question some buddy ah brother
Abdul Rahim Green that those who practice
Islam will go to paradise do those who practice Islam will go
to hell  The answer was
convincing and was in the reply I am Shar brother
Abdul Rahm Green I have given a very convincing
reply I have been understand certain of his
points I know he is a very good speaker
Mashallah but regarding the reply that will
Muslim go to Jannah and non Muslim
go to hell brother the requirement to go to
Jannah is given in Sir Al Asar chapter number
103 verse number 1 that is
the token of time man is in a state
of lust except those who have faith those who have done
dawah and those
people to profess and pass the requirement for
any human to go to Jannah is four things
iman faith and discuss point of iman rich deed a
p truth and at peel to pay if any one of
four is missing under normal circumstances you shall not go
to Jannah only by calling
yourself Abdullah Mohammed  Sultan Zakir will
not take you to Jannah just by saying
I am a Muslim you will not go to Jannah I said
in my talk Allah says in Sura An Kaboot
chapter 29 verse number two just by saying you
believe just by saying I am a Momin I am
a Muslim do you think you go to Jannah
Allah will definitely take you just by saying
I am a Muslim he will not go to Jannah a
person who practices Islam Islam comes
from the root of Taw Salam which means peace it's mere
Sabil to God a person submit to God is called
Muslim so person follow reason and
submitting to Mighty God is Muslim so any one
submit to Mighty God what ever his
name be he will go to Jannah the criteria
to go to Janna is having Iman in the pillar of Allah the
Mighty God is his messenger about after all
books at doing his deed and
submitting will to Almighty God if  You submit a
will to Almighty God in Arabic it is called as religion
of Islam but it does mean that if you
live in Pakistan live in Saudi Arabia
go to Jannah no all the people in Saudi
Arabia l in Pakistan Allah wa Lam
Allah Alone knows whether they go to Jannah or
not the person who will go to paradise brother is one who
obeys the commandment of Almighty God the
person who obeys the commandment of Almighty God
and I discuss many in my talk if you obey these
commandments of Almighty God just by
name calling yourself Muslim Mohammad
Abdullah that will not take you to Jannah it is not
compulsory to change your name the name
is not a Muslim name so that does mean you will go
to Jannah we pretend that brother
inshallah he has reverted he was a
Christian so the name will not take you to
Janna your deed will take you believing your
deeds a people and  Act people to pesh if
your deeds are right if iman is right and act people
to pesh and pesh inshallah any
human being he shall go to janna hope the ans quen
next que badar my name and
profession raja ji f new
college my var social m so my duty t
mat
krishna wa a muslim
puri you to rig are united in supposing the
mumman
right you
set my mind mind are so attractive but
personal
perspective and if you find so your wor are
corrupted and your mind is corrupted
the concept of beauty it is changing nerve
clip was beautiful but it is not so now a rar ra
first
and r also suggested for the original
text but it created only the fine and
fundamental n you are poet to particular religions if you find
no rng in r k ut what the thing that happen
in gujarat 000
muslims are mud in the streets now  God come
only communist and some make effort for their
people are following the religious values ​​and for you like people come people so please all the people who are
free from all
social media like come a question la kalam
alam
nay according to him brother he sang clay
pat was beautiful today she is not Aishwarya Rai
is number one for you not for
me so what is beautiful for you may not be
beautiful for me I do agree with you it
is a perspective I do agree with you Aishwarya
Rai may be number one for you not for
me so we realize but the concept of
difference changes and I give the example what
is modest in America is not modest here
what is modest is not me in
America on that side I do agree with you if you
think that marry more than one wife is
suppress the woman who is going to take care of
the mills of women you who will take care will
your communist movement take care Allah
in the Glorious Quran gave  You the solution to the
problem of human kind the solution can go
down your throat I am
asking you question today there are millions of women more than
men who go take care of them who even if you give them
charity every month that charity
will not be sufficient see man and woman have been
sexual by nature Allah says in
Quran in room chatter number 30 21 I put love and sorrow
between hearts I am a medical
doctor I am a medical doctor a woman can not remain
in life can it not possible what will happen they
to prostitution what will come
for them what the solution no solution
Allah give the solution our creator the
solution can go down the throat see the problem i
brother the solution you give a better solution can you
think of better
in Islam it is not compulsory to marry  More than
one wife it is not compulsory to marry for I don't know
of single Indian Muslim get for
wife I don't know of any there are other
foreigner Muslim who have got you have to
believe brother this is the solution everybody can not marry more than one woman everybody can not but certain men who can do
justice between the
wives Allah has given them permission if they can do
justice what is troubling you at all understand are we suppressing them we
uplifting them the so called modern talking about
in America in the name of art and
culture what are they doing there disrespecting the
women their talk of women liberalization is nothing but it is an
exploitation of a body
degradation of honor and depravation of a
soul the western society claims to uplift
the women have actually degraded to a Kanak
bin to a mistress and society butterflies
watch  Are hidden behind the colorful screen of
art and culture in the name of art and
culture Ash Rai what is
that modeling is it right so the problem is
bad you have to put your thinking right is
important we don't want to sell our daughters we don't want to
sell our mothers if you want you can do it
and the famous ad I'm told which I give
the example last time of the
bead someone told me very famous ad no
[praise]
don't do it
in America in America you have cut
mistresses for 10 20 no one can stop you so in
communism having mistresses is allowed having more than one and we have to
give our rights you can't ill
treat everyone you have to give our honor
you have to give your property that dozen go
down your throat who is degree in the women
you are me you know in America one of the most
advanced countries these Americans you talk  About
That Islam Degrades the Women Do You Know
Out of Those People Accepting Islam Today
Islam is the Fastest Going Religion Out
of Those People Accepting
Islam Two Third of the People Are Women If
Islam Degrades the Women Then Why Are the
American Women Accepting Islam Why Are the
American Men Accepting
Islam Who Force Doctor Abu Ana Bilal
to Accept Islam Who Force Badr Abdu Rahm
Green to Accept Islam Who If You See the
Women Two Third of the People Are Women They Are
Accepting Islam Why If Islam
Degrades the Women Why Will They Accept
Islam Because They Not
Islam Gives Sentiment to the One
Islam Uplifting That Security May Not Go
With the Purpose of Making Money in Art and
Culture Like the Politicians Want to Divide and
Rule People Art and Culture Talking About
Uplifting Damn Beauty Contest They Selling
Cosmetics They Make Billions of Dollars You
Not Beauty Contest for What in the  Name of
beauty contest they are making billions of dollars
so just because they want to make billions of dollars they have many
of them to go and see so if you
believe brother we don't believe in biting
of women in front of public we respect them we
love them and we respect them we don't
degrade them we have
non muslim
sisters the answer that you gave me your logic
and statistics made me think for a while
but I still have a point to be clear probably I mean at
previous point of
time in those days men had to go to the
battlefield the only source of income for women was
through men but now times are changing
and probably in the future times will still more
change and women might go to the
battlefield and women and right now women are
going for jobs and probably the
mortality rate for women might increase to at that
point of time is it ok to
Modify and say that there can be just one
wife for a man after all religion is for
mortal creatures like us and not for
God very good question at that time in
vers may be men were dying more and I agree
with her now the times of vers have changed but even today there were more men
dying
in the gulf there were more men died in
Afghanistan and more men died in Vietnam and
more men died but the percentage was much less as
compare to the older I agree with you today I
give the status more people are dying of
cigarette smoking they are men than women more
people dying of alcohol more men than
women accidents more men than women I do agree
with you that now women started going
to the battle field and in America no there was then
USA just a few years back they
started a women section women going and
the big section of women joining the  Military
do you know the President of America that
time it was Bill Clinton I think Bill
Clinton only had to oppose justice in the
Parliament you know 96 women were raped by
the
superior you had to oppose is in the
Parliament majority of the women that take
part in this battle field they are raped by the
superior when you have shoulder to shoulder
going to war what will happen see this is
statistics
sister this is statistics of America
the problem I do agree with you sister I do
agree with your question your questions are
innocent because you don't know the
statistics do you know the statistics I do agree
women are going for jobs in
America do you know in America every day
according to the statistic of 1996 US
Department of Justice
273 women are being raped every day every three
to second one woman is being raped we are
here in  This order is for the past three
hours. For the past three hours, more than 300
women may have been raped in the USA till the time
I am here.
Islam is not against women working.
Islam is not against women working, but it is the
duty of the man to be on the bed. They can
work, but it should be modest work. It should not be
modeling, dancing, singing, and intermingling
with the gents. Working is allowed, sister, but if you do that
work which is immodest, there are
high chances that you may be degraded. They may be emo. Yes,
sister, you have some comments. I am not talking about
anyone, I mean degrading the
modesty of women. Kind of jobs, I am talking about
modest jobs, from driving it myself, there are
the number of women drivers
in the world are increasing. What at one
point of time, let's say of hypothetical
situation, at one point of time, the number of
women  Drivers in the world increase and the
mortality rate of women increase At that
point of time is it okay for us to
accept a religion and say that a man can have just one I am not just talking about this
particular aspect of any religion
alone any aspect of religion is it
okay to modify religions as times are
changing very good question that can we modify regions
as times are changing if the religion is
not perfect it requires modification if the
region is perfect no modification
required then if the religion has a problem then I told you
point out a single fault
you are talking hypothetically
after 100
years if women start diving if women die if
women population becomes less if if if sister our
create almighty God knows the future and
I don't know he knows
the future  Said a man is
permitted to have [ __ ] one wife it is not compulsory even if I agree with you even if I agree
woman population becomes same it is not compulsory
for Muslim to have [ __ ] one wife I have only one
wife
sister I have one wife only and I am satisfied with her I don't intend
marrying me they have no
problem if someone can do they have no problem at all to marry I don't want to marry I don't marry but if you marry you should do
justice
between a wife so sister Our almighty God
creator he knows about the future suppose
doctor says he doesn't have sinite but if the
sinite dozen harm me and if I have it
hypothetical the doctor knows but a doctor a
human being can make mistake almighty God
is the biggest doctor of everything he is the
biggest doctor he knows what is
required for there for I  Said point out
a mistake now tomorrow there may be something then insha
Allah you can come and ask me the
question tomorrow and then all give you the
reply